-Hey, guys, I'm here
with Blake Shelton,
the one and only.
We're at Nobu.
And, Blake,
I can't believe this is true,
but you've never tried
sushi before.
-I mean, not the raw --
like, the raw stuff, no.
♪♪
Don't eat this.
This is a hot towel.
It's not a sushi roll.
So you clean your hands
with this.
See?
-Ah.
-That's how you
clean your hands?
-♪ La-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la ♪
-Have you ever had sake before?
This is -- this is delicious.
It's a wine.
It's a rice wine.
What's -- are you getting
a headache?
-No, I just -- I don't know
what -- rice wine.
-Yeah. Not "race wane."
Rice. Rice wine.
-What did you call it?
-Rice.
You ever had rice before?
Thank you.
Here's to best friends.
Tonight is kind of special.
-Why are you doing this?
-'Cause I love you. That's all.
We're gonna have fun.
This is good. Cheers.
What does it tastes like to you?
-Easter egg coloring.
-Does it to you, too?
-Have you tried
the fresh ginger?
It's pickled ginger.
-I wouldn't know
fresh ginger from old.
-What do you think about this?
-Kind of has the texture
of pre-chewed gum.
-Can we get the next course,
please?
♪♪
Blake, don't -- don't --
-Oh, my God.
-No. Don't be freaked out.
Look at how colorful,
look how beautiful.
Thank you very much.
You should thank them
when they --
-Thank you!
-No, it's too late.
-That's right, Blake.
-Hey, can we get
some more rice wine?
-Which one you wanna go with?
The tuna or the salmon?
-Does it matter?
-Yeah, I think so.
-I don't know the difference.
That right there looks like
a human tongue.
♪♪
The texture is...
Play-Doh.
But I will say this
to you right now...
-Yeah.
-...man to man.
-Thank you.
-I like that.
I like how that tasted, but --
-There's one. Count one.
That's one.
-Okay, that's one.
So what is this?
-This is yellowtail.
Try it in the soy sauce
and then just take half of it.
This is good.
[ Chuckles ]
-I don't like that.
-Oh, come on.
♪♪
Hey, what could be more
disgusting than raw fish?
Whatever this is.
No, I don't want to toast.
-No, I know. I'm sorry.
-Whole thing, huh?
[ Laughter ]
-Can we get some more
of that rice wine?
♪♪
But can you at least tell me
what this is?
-Honestly, I'm not kidding,
I'm just --
-You don't know, okay.
Just shut up.
-It's a fish.
I can look at it.
-Stop talking.
-It's a little fish head.
You see the --
-Stop talking.
-Little fish head.
Do you see it?
-I'm not looking.
I don't want to know
-Look at him.
-It's already in my mouth.
-What's the name
of the new record,
just so I can plug
the record quick?
"Free Popcorn Shrimp"?
Something like that?
-"Free Popcorn Shrimp."
-Yeah.
-No, seriously,
what's the name of it?
It's called, like,
"This Bar Ain't Good Enough"?
-Yes.
-♪ This bar ain't good enough ♪
♪ Bar used to be real tough ♪
-See?
-♪ Bar used to be real rough ♪
♪ Now the bar
ain't tough enough ♪
-Hey, can we get some rice wine?
[ Laughter ]
-[ Southern accent ]
Hey, man, what's real?
You seen Jimmy around here,
my friend?
About 4-foot-9.
A weird look on his face.
Had a lot of rice wine.
Check this out.
[ Laughter ]
Merry Christmas, bitch.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Ready?
Boom! Go for it.
-Oh, my God. It pulled --
No!
♪♪
-What is this?
-It's a sea urchin uni shot.
-I'm sorry?
-Uni. Sea urchin.
-Sea urchin.
-Gonads of the sea urchin.
-Gonads.
-Gonads...
-Sea urchin.
-But you -- you said gonads.
Hey, can we get some
rice wine?
-What are you gonna do?
Are you gonna chew it
or just swallow
the whole thing down?
-I'm gonna pretend
like this isn't happening.
[ Laughter ]
-Hey, what's the name
of the new single?
-"Came Here to Forget."
-[ Laughing ]
Mission accomplished.
I can't. I can't do it.
I can't do it.
[ Audience gasping
and cheering ]
-I did it.
Come on. You don't want
to be that guy.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, my God!
-Ugh! Oh, my gosh.
That was delicious.
-How about a high-five?
-Thank you so much.
♪♪
All right, Blake, we've got
the last course for you.
Had all different kinds
of sushi.
This last one is gonna
blow your mind.
-What?!
-You earned it, buddy.
Big Mac.
-Oh, my gosh!
Now we're talking!
-I love you, man.
-Yes!
-[ Southern accent ]
Two more rice wines.
-I love it!
Can we get some more rice win?
-Blake Shelton, everybody.
[ Laughs ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
Feel like I've known you
for a long time now.
-Stop. I just want you to know
I'm the biggest fan of you.
Like I love you so much
and I just need to get that
[ Cheers and applause ]
out of the way.
Okay.
Now we can be friends again.
-Really? I mean, good.
-Yeah, okay.
-That's pretty cool.
How's Blake doing?
-Let's just talk only
about Blake
because he's so awesome.
-Let's talk about Blake.
How's Blake Shelton?
I love Blake Shelton.
-I love Blake, too.
-I love all of his stuff.
-He loves you.
-He does?
-I love you. You love Blake.
-I made him try sushi
for the first time ever.
-That is so funny
because that was so incredible,
by the way.
It was genius, genius, genius.
And so that night,
he came home and I was like,
"God, I just watched your thing.
It was so funny!"
I'm like, "We should go
to sushi tonight."
Like, I really, like, now,
I really want to eat it.
Like it looks good, you know?
It sounds good.
So, I don't know.
I was like, "Let's go!"
And he was like going along
with it, "Okay, sure," you know.
We get there and, as we get
out the car, some guy goes,
"Oh, hey!"
You know, like, of course,
but everybody recognizes him
wherever he goes.
But we walked in
to the sushi restaurant
and literally
the entire restaurant
like, stood up and was like,
"Blake!"
Like it was like --
-He's Mr. Sushi now.
-It was like the whole world
had just watched it
[ Laughter ]
and we like walked in the room.
I felt so bad because he really
is like a country boy.
Like he does not like going out.
-No. He kept calling sake
[ As Blake ] rice wine.
-[ As Blake ]
Rice wine.
-Rice wine.
-Give me more
of that rice wine.
-How cute is that?
-I don't want to --
No, he's pretty cute, yeah.
-He's pretty cute.
I went out to --
Yeah, I know.
-[ Laughs ]
-I think he's the cutest.
[ Laughter ]
-And the milking one
was good, too.
-I know.
We like to show each other
new things.
-I tried to show that
to my children.
I was like, "I'm not sure
if this is appropriate.
Like this is borderline --
-Just milking a cow.
-Yeah, well, it was weird.
[ Laughter ]
It was like, "What?"
-Do you show each other
new things?
I mean, because he's not
an L.A. guy, right?
-No, no, actually, not at all
and I think that
he's quite miserable
when he's not in the woods
or like somewhere like in camo.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, there's got to be --
there has to be camouflage
five feet in his radius,
or else he doesn't --
-he freaks out.
-He really likes to be
camouflaged.
-[ Laughs ]
He's here tonight.
He's the couch. There's Blake.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh! There he is.
-You couldn't even tell
that he's here.
He's really good.
[ Cheers and applause ]
He's the best.
The best and he commits.
He commits.
But you took him to Disneyland.
-I took him, yes.
And he'd never been
to Disneyland.
I was like, "You are --
-What?!
-Your life is not even
complete yet.
-Yeah!
-Like, what are you doing?"
-I know!
-And --
-Did he like it?
-I was nervous because I know
that like, for me, like,
obviously, I just go anywhere.
Like I know I'm going
to get like hounded
or pictures or whatever,
but I don't mind,
you know what I mean?
And for him, he's just --
he's not used to that.
Like I said, he's in the woods
most of the time.
-He just hides out, yeah.
-But yeah,
we went and it was crazy.
It was like
a billion people there.
-Did he do all like --
Did he do Space Mountain
or did he do --
-He won't do
the roller coasters.
He's totally like --
[ Laughter ]
It was -- That was literal--
-I'm writing this down.
Sorry.
[ Laughter ]
-That was almost
a deal-breaker for me.
-Really?!
-Yeah. I was like,
"I don't know."
-What does he mean,
he doesn't do roller coasters?
He's Blake Shelton.
-I know. Weird.
[ Laughter ]
Actually, imagine, though,
because he doesn't fit
in anything.
So like we would be on --
We did go on --
-Because he's like a giant.
-What is it called? Matterhorn.
-Oh, yeah.
-He did that one but he barely
fit inside the little thing.
Like his knees are like
up like this.
[ Laughter ]
-Like Magilla Gorilla
in the car?
-[Both] Yeah.
-Did he go
on It's a Small World?
-Yep, yes, yeah.
-That's my jam. That's my jam.
I mean, I love that one.
I mean, I got to do that one.
[ Laughter ]
I love -- That's my favorite.
I bring the "babies" there...
-Aww.
-...Gwen, yeah,
but, clearly, it's for me.
[ Laughter ]
I'm like, "We got to go.
Let's do it one more time.
The babies want to go on again."
[ Laughter ]
I'm like so excited.
Like, "Let's do it!"
Oh, my God, I'm crying
and singing
in different languages.
-I would love going there.
-Like, "Oh my gosh."
[ Laughter ]
I love it. So,
here's a photo I saw.
I thought this was
pretty awesome.
It's a picture of Blake
and you at Disneyland.
But then look at this.
It says, "My First Visit."
[ Laughter and applause ]
You got a pin.
You got a button on him.
-That's so cute!
-Gwen has learned how
to bake bread,
really good sourdough bread.
We're just -- literally it's
like, you know,
"Little House on the Prairie"
out here.
Like, she makes bread.
I've been building a fence
and gardening.
And we're pretty self-sufficient
out here.
As a matter of fact,
I don't know --
this interview,
I wanted to do it,
but we actually have a schedule
that we already
had lined out for today
and I don't think
we can put it off any longer.
It's up to you, if you just want
to go ahead and start.
-Hey, Jimmy.
-Oh, my -- yay!
Finally!
-We talked a lot about this.
Yeah, I'm going to be helping
Blake grow out his mullet.
So, you know,
today we had already scheduled
that it was haircut day.
So, I have my clippers.
I got my attachments.
-We got to do this.
-Oh, my God!
-I got to get a haircut.
But go ahead with your questions
'cause you're a very good,
interesting interviewer
and I don't want to miss...
-Oh, my gosh.
-...any of the good things
that you got to ask me.
-Thank gosh you took off
that camouflage jacket
'cause I didn't -- I noticed
I didn't think you had arms
for a second.
-[ Laughs ]
-Oh, my God.
Are you gonna give him a mullet?
Please give him a mullet.
Please.
-Oh, yeah.
-[ Laughs ]
-I've never seen more untouched
hair in my life,
until I'm looking
at yours right now.
-Hey --
-I mean, do you really like --
Did you literally
wake up and go,
"Oh, my God!
I've got to do a TV show!"?
-I -- This is --
I haven't cut it because I'm not
sure if I should cut it.
-Well.
-That's the answer?
-You should do a mullet.
It's coming back.
-Blake, this is
really interesting --
I love seeing
Gwen cut your hair.
This is fantastic.
-How does it look?
-I think it looks good.
-You look like
you're really handling
this whole quarantine well.
-Oh, is that a joke
about my weight?
That's a fat joke, isn't it,
Jimmy?
[ Laughter ]
That's a fat joke, isn't it?
-No, it's not --
-You're right, though.
-It's not that at all.
It's just --
-Is that a good angle?
-Oh, my gosh.
No, no, no.
I'm -- Dude, you gone punk.
Your hair's punk.
It's crazy, man.
That's what happens to a man.
-I love it.
-We get to see
the real Blake Shelton, finally.
-Hey, will you --
one last request,
will you put a J
and an F here
for Jimmy Fallon?
Please.
Please, please.
-Sure.
-I'm so happy to see both
of you guys
and I got to tell everyone
watching at home,
"Nobody But You" is the song
from the album
"Fully Loaded: God's Country,"
but it is so beautiful,
and you guys do it so well,
and I actually --
I showed it
to my wife earlier today.
'Cause you guys just recorded
it for us, thank you.
But I loved it.
Great performance.
-We did, just for you.
-I know, my name's --
I think you mentioned my name,
"Hey, Jimmy," I think you said.
-I'm literally putting
your initials
in my head right now, Jimmy.
I'm not kidding.
-See, these are why
these shows are fun
because you would never
do this in real life.
-She just said they're not
showing up very well
because of the gray.
-[ Laughs ]
-Oh, no, that looks terrible.
[ Laughs ]
-Blake, get right in there.
Get real close
so I can really see it.
Yeah!
-There's the F,
and here's the J.
-Oh, my gosh.
Dude, you are so "Tiger King"
right now, you have no idea.
[ Laughter ]
-[ Claps ]
I love you guys
and stay safe, okay?
-We love you.
Thanks for having us
on "The Tonight Show" today!
-Is there any --
Now that you and Blake
really know each other...
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-...yeah --
is there anything like, "Honey,
let me have this one"?
-I tried pulling all of those
things out, like, of course,
'cause, I mean,
at the end of the day, like,
I want to win, too, you know?
I'm not actually
super competitive,
but when it comes to, like,
people's dreams,
you get really attached.
And my actual team
this season are very lovable.
I love them so much that
I think I'm probably gonna beat
Blake and Kelly and John.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah. It's going to happen.
-Well, the first episode
aired earlier tonight,
and we got to see
your competitive side.
And, actually, you blocked --
-It's -- I have a little one.
-You blocked Blake.
-I blocked Blake.
It rhymes. It's perfect.
-Yeah, exactly. Yeah.
-I mean, it's actually
really, really exciting,
'cause if you have a block, you
can actually push your button,
and they don't even know.
And they turn around.
"Yeah, I'm gonna get them!"
And they're fighting and they
realize that they're blocked,
so the person
can't even choose them.
So, I blocked Blake,
and that was really exciting.
-Because you knew --
-Yeah.
Because I knew that
me and Blake have
similar tastes in, like,
voices and I knew this girl
was very original,
very, very cool
and I knew he was going to push.
And so I was like --
And I was right.
I turned around.
She had fringe on.
So I was like, "Okay, fringe."
-Is he a fringe lover?
-She lives in Nashville.
Like, I was going to be
screwed.
-Yeah, that's totally him.
Yeah.
-He's like --
[ As Blake ] That was not nice.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah.
-[ As Blake ]
That was not nice.
-[ As Blake ] That was not nice.
That's what he was saying.
-[ As Blake ] White wine.
What was it?
[ As Blake ]
Rice wine.
-Yeah, yeah.
-[ Laughs ]
-Blake,
why don't you draw first?
You can draw on that.
And here we go, bud.
I love you.
-Okay.
-Did you say the rules?
-Love you, man.
-Yeah, I said the rules already.
-Was that a high-five?
-That was a double high-five.
But then I was gonna go
for a hug,
and I just got ignored.
You have very big hands.
-Just edit the show.
-Let's sit.
-Oh, yeah, sorry.
Please sit there.
-Thank you.
-I like the letter F.
[ Cheers ]
-Is that right?
-Yep.
-Yeah, because friend.
-Right.
-Yeah, that's right.
-Yeah.
-[ Laughs ]
All right.
-Now, I draw what this says
on the back?
-That's correct.
How many --
How many words are in this?
You can say --
-That's cheating.
-No, no, this game --
-Three words.
-How many words?
-All right, F.
Three words.
-You have the dumbest games
on this show.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Fast, fire --
-No wonder nobody
watches this show, man.
-Fast, fire, Freddy.
[ Laughter ]
Fast Five Freddy.
-Is there a, uh --
-Is there a timer?
-Yeah, there's a timer, yeah.
20 minutes on the clock.
Here we go.
[ Laughter ]
What are you drawing?!
Hey, what is --
what is going on, dude?
Oh, light.
Light.
-Wow!
-Light, light.
-Oh, son of a --
-"Friday Night Lights"!
-Yes!
-Oh, my God!
[ Ding! ]
-What?!
-Oh, my God!
-Way to go, buddy.
Wow!
-You cheated!
-No way, man!
-You knew!
-I would never cheat.
Gigi, it is your turn.
Wow!
-Take that, Gwen Stefani.
-No, no! That's your wife.
That's your wife.
Here we go.
Gigi,
what letter are you going --
what should she pick?
[ Audience shouting ]
They're saying B.
B -- Be careful.
This is Impossible Pictionary.
-I'm gonna go --
I'm gonna go W.
-Oh.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-You're gonna go
to the hardest one.
-[ Laughs ]
Is it really impossible?
-I'm gonna get it.
Watch.
-Two words.
-Okay, okay.
I'm gonna try.
-Come on, girl.
-Winner, winner!
Win!
-Football-watching...
-I'm a volleyball player.
Okay. Um...
-W, two words.
-W.
You guys can't -- oh.
Um, flag.
Okay.
-Okay.
-Flag football.
Um...
-W, Gwen.
-Oh, W.
Uh...
Oh, my God -- arena.
W?
-Oh, I know what it is.
I think I know what it is.
I know what it is.
I think I know.
-You can't guess.
-You're football crazy.
-Um...
-Oh, my God.
Flag?
American --
Um...
-Where is that?
[ Buzzer ]
[ Sad trombone ]
-Oh.
-What is it?
-I'm sorry.
-Is it Washington --
-Washington Commanders?
-It was
the Washington Commanders.
But I was --
-Oh, my God.
-Ah!
-Whoo!
[ Applause ]
Impossible.
It's Impossible Pictionary.
-I would never --
-The Commanders.
I didn't even...
-But you guys --
-I was trying to get Washing--
I know Washington --
Washington, D.C., but I was
trying to get that word out.
-I mean, we really got two
because I knew
what that one was.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-Washington Commanders
is harder than
"Friday Night Lights."
-Judges, can we get 2 points
'cause Blake got that one?
-Yeah.
[ Ding! ]
-Thank you.
All right.
[ Audience boos ]
Which letter?
-H!
-H.
-Football episode...
-I got a very --
That was a thirsty H.
"H!"
All right.
[ Laughter ]
H -- here we go.
Okay.
Okay, bud.
Two words.
-And it starts with H.
-Correct.
[ Laughter ]
-Uh, ha--
Hair.
[ Light laughter ]
Draw something!
[ Laughter ]
Boobs!
-Oh, oh!
-Pads, chest, plate, pads!
Cleavage!
It's cleavage!
-No!
-It has to be.
[ Laughter ]
Okay.
Gigi got it.
-Has -- What?
-It starts with an H!
-I know it!
You're drawing boobs!
-No!
[ Buzzer ]
This!
I'm doing this!
-Is that Hooters?
-It's not Hooters!
-Oh, it's not.
-It is, isn't it, Gigi?!
-Hail Mary!
Hail Mary.
-Oh!
-Hail Mary.
-Oh, my gosh.
-God.
-You're up, Gwen.
-Okay.
-That was a nun!
That was a nun I was drawing!
-Will you please for --
-I was drawing a nun, and you --
You know what you did.
[ Laughter ]
Say a couple Hail Marys
when you get home.
-Stop trying to be funny.
We're trying
to win this contest.
-No, I'm not being funny!
That was me drawing hands.
That's how I pray!
-But Hail Mary
is throwing the football.
-That's how I pray!
Hail Mary, you do that.
-Wish me luck.
-It's gonna be great.
[ Laughter ]
Take it word by word.
-Okay.
I'm gonna pick --
I'm gonna pick B for Blake.
-Oh!
[ Applause ]
-'Cause I love Blake!
-That's a good partner.
-My wife right there.
Here we go.
-Oh, my gosh.
We got such a good one.
-We did? Are you sure?
-Oh, yeah!
Okay.
Two, uh -- two words.
-Okay.
-What letter was it?
-B.
-All right, B.
Sorry. Two words.
-Bunny.
-Um, okay.
Um, um, um, um...
[ Laughter ]
Bunny.
Quack.
Bunny duck.
-Okay, um...
-Bunny smoking a joint.
Flying.
[ Laughter ]
-Bunny smoking a joint?
It's football.
-Okay, um, um.
Okay, wait.
Um...
-Okay, wait.
Was bunny right, Gwen?
Magic!
No.
Football.
Okay.
[ Buzzer ]
Oh, oh! Hot wings!
-Yes!
[ Ding! ]
-That's how you do it!
You got it -- hot wings!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Hot wings!
-Buffalo, yeah!
-Fantastic!
Fantastic.
-Buffalo, right?
-It was Buffalo wings.
Yeah, it counts.
We get it.
Hot wings, all right.
But the score is 2-1.
I just heard from the judges
this is the last round.
This one's worth
a thousand points.
-They said that to you
in your earpiece?
-They said it in my earpiece,
yeah.
-Okay.
[ Laughter ]
-And, oh, man,
do I need this one.
You want to draw, please?
Yeah, thank you.
Gigi, you want to draw?
-Oh, oh, oh!
I got you, yeah.
-You both draw at the same time.
-Okay.
-Oh, okay.
-The letter.
And whoever guesses first, wins.
-What?
-I'm still processing,
but this is not working for me.
-Me versus you.
You just got hot wings, great.
-Are we drawing the same thing?
-You're drawing the same thing.
-Sorry.
-It's a T, all right.
-We're both competing
against each other.
-Yeah.
But you know I love you.
[ Laughter ]
-All right.
All right.
-What are you --
What are you laughing at?
-Don't draw what I draw.
-All right.
Starts with a T,
and it is football-themed.
Yeah.
Pfft!
What in the world are you --
[ Laughter ]
What are you doing?
-A turd, turd!
[ Laughter ]
-What is happening?
What is going on?!
Blake Shelton, stop it!
Gigi, stop it!
What is happening?!
-Oh. Nut?
Oh, my God!
[ Funk music plays ]
Act it out?
-He's drawing an actual hole
in something.
-Taint? Taint?
[ Laughter ]
Tent?!
I didn't say -- no.
What are you drawing?
[ Buzzer ]
-Can we act it out?
-Please don't act it out!
Please don't act that out!
Blake, get rid of
whatever that thing is.
That --
What is that?
What's wrong with you?
-That is a belt that is tight.
-Okay. All right.
Hold on.
All right.
I didn't know it was a belt.
All right, it's a belt.
-Tight end!
-Tight end, Gwen!
-Yes!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-I thought
that was something else.
-100%, that's testicles.
-Oh, no, that's not --
[ Laughter ]
-It does start with a T.
My thanks to Blake Shelton,
Gigi Hadid.
Gwen Stefani!